un petit air de campagne et pourtant ici
on est en ville à orléans même une
ancienne parcelles viticoles a été
transformé en maraîchage bio depuis deux
ans un projet initié par trois
passionnés dont le but était de faire
revivre cette exploitation de plus de
4000 mètres carrés
c'est une terre qui est très sableuse
donc qui boit beaucoup qui a été en
friche pendant des années du coup elle
est assez dur
on a une petite surface vu qu'on est en
contexte urbain on n'a pas des hectares
et des hectares on est sur la moitié
d'un hectare ce qui fait que j'ai pas de
tracteur parce que j'ai pas forcément la
place de faire des allers grosse pour
avoir un tracteur et travailler seul ici
après trente 30 crise sur un sol sableux
c'est assez compact c'est même très
compact donc donc bah l'huile de coude
et puis on y va avec patience et
persévérance et on y arrive depuis avril
nos jeunes maraîchers ont ouvert une
boutique en vente directe indispensable
pour rentabiliser le travail et pour
valoriser leurs produits sont belles
cette petite caisse et petites pommes de
terre il ya un socle de légumes
classiques un fédérer voilà il faut les
avoir et après on essaye de toucher les
gens avec des variétés différentes d
voilà des tomates de toutes les couleurs
les aubergines de toutes les couleurs de
toutes les variétés en faisant attention
évidemment là à la aux qualités
gustatives 1 c'est pas tout une couleur
mais il faut que le légume soit bon
cet espace c'est l'occasion aussi de
diversifier les produits proposés à la
vente
on travaille avec d'autres maraîchers
bio pour compléter en fait notre gamme
et pouvoir fournir donc aux clients
donc les légumes tout au long de la
saison et en quantité une boutique en
ligne complète l'offre
elle permet de commander ses légumes et
de venir récupérer son panier à la ferme
un drive fermiers pour urbains pressés